[Applause]
[Music]
according to a recent study nearly one
third of black americans are hesitant to
get the cova 19 vaccine now we know
covid can be deadly and we know that the
disease has disproportionately affected
black communities so you might be
wondering why are one-third of black
americans suddenly anti-vaxxers how did
we get here well we'd like to answer
that question for you in a segment
called how did we get here
for those of you who don't know
anti-vaxxers are people who are
anti-vaccine measles mumps chickenpox
you name it if there's a disease that
scientists have worked hard to eradicate
over the last century anti-vaxxers have
worked to bring it back in 2019 the
world health organization named them one
of the top 10 global health threats
right after people who cut the seat
belts out of cars
the anti-vaxx movement has been mostly
dominated by rich white people who read
a book written by
an actress named jenny mccarthy in 2007
that claimed vaccines were unsafe which
explains the list of credits on her imdp
page
until now being anti-vaccine has mostly
been a white thing like cargo shorts or
taking a shower without a washcloth so
why are so many black people
disinterested in taking the coven 19
vaccine it's because america has a big
big problem with medical racism now i
know what you're thinking america racist
that sounds about right but how is
medical racism different from regular
old everyday racism well the main
difference is that instead of some
random person being racist to you for
free you pay a doctor to do it black
people aren't usually known for being
anti-vaccine but a lot of us are
anti-taking the vaccine first because
there is a long history of doctors
experimenting on black people to figure
out ways to help white people for
example many of the practices in modern
day gynecology come from experimenting
on slaves the gynecologist is not fun in
2021 so you know the very first speculum
was bad but even after slavery ended
scientists were taught that black bodies
and minds were inferior and because of
this that their bodies belonged to
science even if it was against their
will now i didn't say they thought black
minds and bodies were inferior i said
they were taught this it was part of
their curriculum it came between how to
turn on a bunsen burner and how to get
stains out of your lab coat
in 1932 the united states public health
service conducted the tuskegee study of
untreated syphilis in the negro male
scientists from the u.s government
decided they wanted to see what happens
to black men when syphilis is left
untreated this is what our government
decided to focus on in 1932. gerald
should we solve the great depression we
could or hear me out we could conduct
this insane experiment
now what human being would just sign up
to let syphilis kill them the answer is
no damn body so they got 600 black men
to participate in that study by lying to
them the men thought they were being
treated and instead the government gave
them fake medicine and just let them die
which may sound unbelievable but take a
look around america today letting people
die is kind of our government's thing
the tuskegee experiment remained a
secret until a whistleblower leaked the
information in 1972 and that's when the
study was finally shut down
1972 that is not that long ago we got
rid of this hairstyle before we got rid
of that study and if you think that
story is crazy hold on to your butts
because after the tuskegee study there
was henrietta lacks a black woman who
was dying from cervical cancer in 1951.
doctors harvested her cells without her
permission so they could use them to do
medical research and those cells are
still used by scientists to this day her
family didn't find out about the cell
harvesting until 1975 and they received
zero compensation then a bunch of people
wrote books and an hbo movie about her
and her family didn't receive any of
that money either and you know hbo plays
that movie every february a lot of the
examples i'm giving happened years ago
but the effects of those events are
still felt today a study in 2016
revealed that 40 percent of white
medical students believe that black
people's skin is thicker than white
people's and that as a result we feel
less pain thicker skin metaphorically no
do not make fun of me or i will cry
thicker skin physically also no i bruise
easily and again i will cry but white
doctors thinking black folks actually
have thicker skin and feel less pain
helps explain why black babies are twice
as likely to die during childbirth as
white babies because doctors literally
don't take black women's pain seriously
racism is woven into the fabric of
american medicine black people aren't
suspicious of the covet vaccine because
we read a book by jenny mccarthy a book
i can only assume is mostly pictures
we're suspicious because we've read our
history now personally i hope every
american gets the vaccine as quickly as
possible so we can put this whole
nightmare behind us and i hope
communities of color will be prioritized
when they roll it out but i also can't
blame the black community for being
suspicious of scientists because this is
how we got here lately there's been a
lot of talk about systemic racism
everyone claims they want to fix it but
we can't even agree on what it is we
just know it's bad like poverty or
pollution or the way white people dance
but systemic racism isn't just an idea
it's a real thing there's a place where
you can go and see real live systemic
racism right in front of you it's called
the hood i'm sure you've heard about it
your favorite rapper grew up there
you've probably seen movies about it in
a movie you can tell you're in the hood
because there's always rap music playing
in the background when the brave white
savior goes there to drag jamal away
from the gang so he can play in the big
chess tournament but have you ever
wondered how the hood got that way
systemic racism that's how in the 1930s
america was in the thick of the great
depression the banks had failed and
everyone had lost their homes and
unemployment was at the highest it would
ever be until this idiot came along so
fdr had an idea called the new deal the
new deal gave jobs to nearly every
american set the minimum wage and
created a retirement plan called social
security and it worked for the first
time in american history you could have
a regular job and make a decent living
you wouldn't necessarily be rich but you
wouldn't be poor either they called it
the middle class to get that kind of job
security today you would need three jobs
and an only fan's account
now if you're wondering if this new deal
made things better for black people the
answer is
see part of the new deal was the home
owners loan corporation they were an
organization that guaranteed home loans
for everyone but just like an episode of
friends they didn't include black people
how could they separate the white
applicants from the black applicants
they didn't have to segregation did that
for them because of segregation laws
black people could only live in certain
areas so the united states government
drew up color-coded maps for nearly
every city in america and told the banks
we'll guarantee loans for everyone who
lives anywhere except in the red areas
those just so happen to be the areas
where black people lived like how the
only thing behind glass at walgreens
just so happens to be miss jesse's
they created a system based on racism to
make sure black people couldn't be a
part of this middle class they came up
with a name for it too they called it
redlining we called it the hood but
that's way in the past right like
downton abbey phones and these pants
what does that have to do with now well
how many of you watching right now live
in or know someone who lives in a home
that their parents or grandparents owned
that's called generational wealth and
home ownership is the number one driver
of wealth in america number two of
course is how many beanie babies you
have you can use a home to pay for
college or start a business or you know
not be homeless but if you look at
almost any major american city most of
the formerly redlined areas are still
majority black and low income that's
because banks didn't stop doing this
until
hold on let me look it up let's see when
did banks stop they never stopped homes
in majority black neighborhoods are
valued at 25 percent lower than homes in
white areas even when the crime rate and
the neighborhood amenities are exactly
the same and because school funding is
based on home values the average
non-white school district receives two
thousand two hundred and twenty six
dollars less per student than a white
school district which is why the gym in
a public school in a black neighborhood
looks like this
and the gym at a white school looks like
this
there's even studies that show schools
in black neighborhoods have smaller
libraries meanwhile at the white school
they're checking out encyclopedia brown
from here
and because wealth and education are the
number one factors for crime police are
more likely to patrol these
neighborhoods which is why even though
there is no difference in the rate of
drug use between white and black people
let me say that again there is no
difference in the rate of drug use
between white and black people
black people are three and a half times
more likely to be arrested for drugs
it's like a reverse hunger games where
the odds are never in your favor
most drug arrests occur in redlined
areas and studies show courts hand out
20 percent longer sentences to black
people who commit the same crimes as
white people
wait maybe that's why white people dance
like that it's the dance of a person
with no consequences so maybe all of
this is why the average white family has
10 times the wealth of a black family
not because black people like jordans
and shiny rims but because there is a
system designed specifically to make it
true home ownership in america is more
rigged than a basketball hoop at coney
island and maybe that's why black people
are always rapping and bragging about
where we come from we're not celebrating
the hood we're letting you know that we
survived a system that took our free
labor and our tax dollars and gave it to
everyone but us we're telling the world
in no uncertain terms that y'all can't
kill us and we won't die so if you want
to know what systemic racism looks like
just go to the hood and tell jamal good
luck at the chess tournament
it's black history month yay
every morning this month i wake up and
look to see what's waiting for me under
the tubman tree will it be a white
person telling me what martin luther
king would have wanted or better yet
someone saying why do we need a black
history month how would you like it if
we had a white history month you might
be thinking that's crazy the only reason
we know about such notable white
achievements as betsy ross's apparently
groundbreaking ability to use a needle
and thread or paul revere's remarkable
ability to scream and ride a horse at
the same time is because every month is
white history month but hear me out
i think we do need a white history month
because the american history that's
taught in schools is so whitewashed we
don't learn the real story we learn lies
like george washington chopping down a
cherry tree but not the fact that george
had 18 slaves before he turned 18.
18 slaves when i was 18 i didn't have 18
shirts i had three shirts and they all
looked like this
each one of them cuter than the last
we learned that abraham lincoln said
four score and seven years ago but not
that he said i am not nor ever have been
in favor of bringing about in any way
the social and political equality of the
black and white races there must be the
position of superior and inferior and i
am in favor of having the superior
position assigned to the white race
they don't put that on the penny
partially because it would make the
penny too long and partly because our
schools don't teach an honest version of
american history and that's why we need
white history month history shouldn't
just be a list of names and dates it's
supposed to give us context for the
present how can we learn about harriet
tubman and frederick douglass and mlk's
response to inequality without
understanding the true history of the
country that enshrined that inequality
into law
for example in regular history they tell
you the second amendment was created to
protect against tyranny but during white
history month you would learn the truth
that the right to bear arms was added to
the constitution so white men could keep
their slaves in check
that is a true fact see how much we're
learning white history month is fun i
hope you're taking notes in your white
history month trapper keeper
see at the time the constitution was
written most states required every
able-bodied man who lived there to serve
on a slave patrol these states had
posses of white men to keep black people
in line and in the 1700s they didn't
have the kind of advance adhesive
technologies we have now so slaves
couldn't wear name tags so the slave
patroller guys just stopped every black
person over time those slave patrols
eventually evolved into militias and
during the revolutionary war those
militias became the american army and
when the war ended america had a bunch
of roving bands of men who had guns so
they put those men in charge of putting
down slave rebellions and eventually
they put them in charge of enforcing all
the laws or as they called it back then
policing if you're still taking notes i
bet your trapper keeper just exploded
now when the southern states decided
they'd rather own human beings than be
part of america these militias became
the confederate army and after the civil
war the militias came back home with
nothing to do so a few of them started a
fun fraternity called the circle of
brothers now you've probably never heard
of the circle of brothers fraternity
because they always lost at the
homecoming step shows plus they use
their greek name kuklos meaning circle
and of course clan meaning family you
call them the ku klux klan that's who
enforced racial terrorism during
reconstruction that's who used violence
to enforce jim crow laws that's who
carried out the lynchings during the red
summer of 1919.
google it
that's who still stops and frisks black
people at 10 times the rate of white
people that's who still shoots and kills
unarmed black citizens at three and a
half times the rate of whites because
for most of america's history there's
been no difference between the clan the
police and plain old racists so why
don't we all know this because while
southern men were busy forming the kkk
southern women were busy forming a fun
club called the united daughters of the
confederacy the united daughters joined
school boards and formed lobbying groups
to make textbooks more favorable to
confederates and they got so powerful
that textbook publishers had to get
their approval before school boards
agreed to purchase social studies books
ensuring that their version of history
is the one that got taught in schools it
is impossible to understand politics the
black community's relationship with the
police or why we even need to say black
lives matter if we don't learn the
history of this country so yes let's
have a white history month let's have 12
of them otherwise we'll never learn
information that's crucial to
understanding our own country like the
fact that once upon a time there were
slave patrols who became militias who
became revolutionary army who became the
police who became the confederate army
who became the kkk just because they
don't teach that in schools doesn't mean
you can't learn it but you're gonna need
a lot more trapper keepers america is
known for three things baseball apple
pie and not spending money on social
services we're one of the richest
nations in the world but we don't have a
lot of cool things other developed
countries have like the ability to go to
the dentist without taking on a loan but
how did we get here let's find out in a
segment called how did we get here
it seems like these days no one can
agree on anything is climate change real
should we double mask does sugar belong
on grits well apparently all this
division is caused by this thing called
economic anxiety i'm sure you've heard
of it it's a euphemism that describes a
whole set of confusing beliefs people
with economic anxiety love small
government but are happy to spend
billions on prisons or a border wall
they hate regulations but they love to
regulate women's bodies
the myth of economic anxiety has been
around since slavery because america
loves a euphemism that's why we call it
climate change instead of everybody
gonna drown if y'all stop playing
it's why we call woody allen a director
instead of an alleged child molester who
is also very ugly but economic anxiety
and all the things it's a euphemism for
are caused by a concept called the
zero-sum fallacy
that's the belief that one person's gain
means another person's loss
think of america as a pie
this should be an easy analogy to follow
because at any given moment 90 percent
of americans are eating pie basically
economically anxious people think that
when anyone else gets a piece of pie
there must be less pie to go around they
believe that if everyone gets health
care insurance premiums will rise or if
we raise minimum wages companies will
lay off workers or if we spend more
money on public education then the
police won't have money for bear
essentials like this
now to me the benefits of spending money
on social services is clear it's obvious
we should be doing it just like it's
obvious we should all watch bridgerton
alone when our husband isn't home but
many americans don't feel that way they
get nervous about spending money on
services that benefit all americans but
that wasn't always the case according to
a recent new york times article in 1960
70
of white americans believed that the
government ought to guarantee a job for
anyone who wants one and ensure a
minimum standard of living for everyone
in the country by 1964 that number had
dropped to just 35 percent now what
could have happened between 1960 and
1964 to change the way white people felt
what could that have been can you guys
think of anything
that's right when white americans
thought the social safety net was for
them they were all for it but when it
started to look like black americans
might also get a piece of that pie they
changed their mind fortunately very few
economic systems are modeled after
desserts in fact it's the opposite you
get more pie when you share more pie
take minimum wage for example studies
show that companies that pay a living
wage actually make more money and then
the people making a living wage boost
the economy by spending money on things
like food and clothes and whatever this
is
if everyone had health care hospitals
wouldn't have to overcharge people to
make up for patients who don't have
health care the surest way to lower
costs is to insure more people it's also
the surest way to stop people from
googling can i take my own appendix out
at home
do you ever wonder why there's a lot
less crime in rich neighborhoods it's
because crime is caused by poverty poor
education and lack of resources so if we
spend more money on education mental
health services and job training crime
will go down now where will we get all
this extra money from well since we
already know that investing in these
things lowers crime how about using some
of the big pile of money sitting in
police funding if only there was a name
for this economic concept
oh well
more education and job training means
more people making a living wage which
means more tax revenue which means more
pie which is great because as we've
already established americans love pie
now people with economic anxiety will
call these things government handouts
but they're not worried about the
government handing money out they're
worried about who the government is
handing money to
they only want it to go to certain
people well guess what that's all of our
money it comes from the taxes we all pay
and we all deserve a piece of that pie
no matter your race gender sexuality or
creed even if your creed is apollo
in fact the only way we will ever get
rid of economic anxiety is if we stop
hoarding so much damn pie unless of
course economic anxiety was just racism
all along
last sunday oprah interviewed meghan
markle and prince harry about their
experience stepping back from the royal
family and a lot of the interview was
about the pain megan had suffered at the
hands of the british press they are
truly evil to her that whole country
talks about megan like she stole their
man which
i guess she did
now i look at meghan markle and i see a
nice lady in well-tailored clothes but
when the press writes about that same
woman all of a sudden she's difficult
not appropriate unsuitable as a wife and
my favorite
uppity huh
uppity i wonder why they chose that word
i think i can explain in a segment
called how did we get here
listen i'll be the first to admit that
i'm not quite up on my british culture
until recently i thought earl was a
title bestowed on the oldest man in any
auto mechanics shop but i do know a dog
whistle when i hear one a dog whistle is
coded language that's used to insult a
group of people while maintaining
deniability to the audience at large dog
whistles use language that sounds normal
to the majority of people but that
communicates a very specific very
message to a smaller intended audience
for example the dictionary definition of
uppity is self-important or arrogant but
that word is exclusively used to
describe black people who supposedly
don't know their place
i've never heard a white person be
called uppity in my entire life but then
again i work in television so maybe i
just don't know any self-important white
people
so when you say uppity you can pretend
you're just calling someone
self-important in a race neutral way but
we all know what you're really saying is
that they think of themselves too highly
for a black person
it especially gets used to describe
black people who ask to be treated the
same as white people which isn't a lot
to ask especially when you're a literal
freaking princess isn't finding yourself
important exactly what being royal is oh
so only white princesses get to order
birds to brush their hair let megan have
her birds
there are a million dog whistles like
this and they all essentially mean a
different version of the same thing
so when tabloids call meghan markle
uppity or exotic or duchess difficult
what they're really saying is she's
black and we don't like that and it
makes us crazy when you're black and
fancy because fancy is supposed to be
our thing but dog whistles aren't just a
british thing americans might not be
great at men's fashion or men's soccer
but we are amazing at dog whistles like
when trump told voters that low-income
housing was going to destroy the suburbs
he was saying
black people are going to move into your
white neighborhoods and you should be
scared they can season your food or
teach your women to dance
or when trump planned a rally in tulsa
on juneteenth
people who didn't know the significance
of tulsa were like okay but racists
heard that dog whistle and were like
as far as ways to be racist go dog
whistles are a great strategy for
politicians because you get to be racist
and pretend you're not and when black
people get mad about the obvious racism
you get to call them politically correct
for canceling you over something you
definitely wink wink weren't doing you
get to have your racist cake and eat it
too and you know that cake is dry as
hell and the kitchen was not clean when
they made it and if you're wondering if
there are dog whistles that exclusively
apply to white people well there are and
they're my favorite kind
if you hear anyone say patriots they're
talking about white people or the new
england football team which in which
case they're still talking about white
people when politicians say working
class they mean working class white
people also known as blue collar people
diner patrons or bruce springsteen fans
black voters are black voters but white
voters are soccer moms or nascar dads or
evangelicals or value voters apparently
only white people play soccer or have
values
just don't say white people they hate
that because white people are people
they get to have individuality and
complex backstories that you have to
empathize with in order to understand
their choices and when black people ask
to be treated that way
we're uppity
there are too many of these terms for me
to cover if you want to learn them all
you'll have to download duolingo or you
can just read one single article about
meghan markle cause they're all in there
and while we're back on the subject i'd
like to take a second to talk about
megan and harry using absolutely no dog
whistles
megan and harry are grown-ups who can do
whatever they want they are hot and
young and rich and they know oprah but
most importantly they are minding their
own dang business meghan markle's life
literally does not affect you in any way
so if you hate megan you need to take a
hard look at yourself and ask why is it
because she ruined your high school
fantasy of marrying a prince who never
knew you existed or
is it that the world has taught you that
black girls are worthless and seeing
megan being loved so fiercely makes you
angry harry would rather be her husband
than your prince and it makes you sick
meghan markle is smart and classy and
brave and she's a better princess than
we deserve and if you're mad at her if
you think you deserve a better princess
than her
that's the definition of uppity earlier
this week a gunman murdered eight people
including six asian women in a hate
crime in atlanta our hearts go out to
the families and communities affected by
this violence no one should have to
experience the pain they are going
through and this event didn't come out
of nowhere how did we get here
let's find out in a segment called how
did we get here
america has a long and well documented
history of anti-asian racism but during
the coronavirus pandemic violent attacks
against asian americans have increased
by 150 percent asian americans have
reported street harassment attacks on
their elders and vandalism of their
businesses one toll in texas graffitied
a ramen shop
do you know how stupid and racist you
have to be to get mad at soup
especially when that soup is delicious
get a grip racists
now it's really impossible trump to say
trump why something like that trump
would happen but i do know that
anti-asian violence spiked after trump
and other republicans started referring
to the coronavirus as the china virus
and other racist terms
and it doesn't surprise me that this
kind of rhetoric would lead to an
increase in violence partly because i
have the common sense god gave a house
fly and partly because america has a
long violent history of scapegoating
asian people
which i a comedian will now try to tell
you about in the five minutes i have
between commercials because the american
school system has failed us all
anti-asian racism in the u.s falls into
a weird duality on one hand there's the
model minority myth well-off and
middle-class asians are seen as the good
successful minorities their success is
so-called proof that racism doesn't
exist and that other minorities just
aren't working as hard but also their
success is not fair because they're
keeping good white kids with a b-minus
average out of harvard by using the
totally dishonest trick of having better
grades now it's the dumbest widest thing
to have a theory that proves your
country isn't racist that is actually a
hierarchy of races obviously not all
asian americans are well off harvard
students and that's where the
double-sided trap of anti-asian racism
comes in
on the one hand you've got the model
minority myth and on the other the
yellow peril myth the myth that asian
people are somehow a threat to the
western world
since the first working-class asian
immigrants arrived in the u.s they've
been seen as disposable labor in the
1860s chinese immigrants arrived to
build the transcontinental railroad for
one-third of the pay of white workers
well chinese men did chinese women
weren't allowed to immigrate because
and i wish i was making this up they
didn't want chinese people to fall in
love here get married and stay
what kind of evil empire tries to outlaw
love
that is some darth vader death star
asian workers have been the targets of
violence and lynchings throughout
history
in 1871 during the chinese massacre 10
of la's chinese residents were killed
in 1885 in rock springs wyoming 28
chinese coal miners were murdered and
the city's chinatown was burned down oh
and fun fact at the time it was illegal
for an asian person to testify in court
against a white person
i know that wasn't an actual fun fact
but it's the closest we're going to get
in this segment
in 1900
one asian person was suspected of having
the plague and the city of san francisco
put up barbed wire and literally
quarantined the entire chinese
population in chinatown while in other
areas people just burned chinese
neighborhoods down i told you these
facts would not be fun but they are
plentiful in 1882 the u.s passed the
chinese exclusion act the first time the
country barred people from immigration
based on race but not the last time
because if there's one thing america
loves to do it's keep people out we're
like the bouncer of countries
during world war ii the united states
imprisoned japanese people including
children because they thought they might
be loyal to the japanese government
which is funny because when i think of
groups who aren't loyal to the us
government that's not who i think of
what i'm trying to say is donald trump
is an [ __ ] but he's not an inventor
he ain't done nothing new he simply
tapped into america's long violent
history of dehumanizing asian americans
now there's been a lot of talk this week
about what we should all do in the wake
of violence in atlanta but
i'd like to talk for a minute about what
we're not going to do
what we're not gonna do is disrespect
the lives that were lost this week by
acting like words don't matter what
we're not gonna do is act like asian
hate doesn't run deep in this country
america does not get to hide from its
racist past or present and what we're
not going to do is act like white
supremacy isn't at the root of all this
contrary to everything this country was
built on
white men don't get to decide who lives
and who dies
white people don't get to decide our
humanity dismantling white supremacy
starts with white people admitting they
have a big problem and black people will
continue to stand in solidarity with our
asian family because white supremacy is
killing us all of us
i remember last summer when people from
all over were protesting and saying
protect black women black lives matter
seeing that felt really great and i want
that feeling for you so just to be extra
explicit
we hate this it's not right your
feelings are valid you deserve to feel
safe you deserve to be safe we love you
this has been how did we get here we are
so saddened by the tragic events in
boulder this week and we're also
frustrated because the majority of
americans are in favor of stricter gun
laws but stricter gun laws will never
pass because of a thing called the
filibuster and that's not the only
damage the filibuster has caused let's
find out why else it's bad in a segment
called how did we get here
a filibuster is an action that a senator
can take to keep the senate from voting
on a bill there are 100 senators so if
any one of them introduces a bill any of
the other 99 can stop it from getting
voted on it's basically legislative
blocking i'm sorry is that sexist
blocking can we say blocking on tv
we just did
so senators stop bills from getting
voted on a lot which is crazy because
voting is their job it would be like if
at any point in the day one of your
co-workers could stand up on his desk
and say i don't think we should ship
office supplies to the southwest region
today and then you all had to stop
working and watch him give a speech
about it meanwhile i'm at home
refreshing my tracking information like
where's madame stapler i have papers to
connect
the filibuster is just a long-winded way
to keep things from getting done and it
isn't even in the constitution it was
created in 1806 by aaron burr the bad
guy from hamilton
leslie i love you and you can get it and
i'm willing to wait for it but the
filibuster didn't start to become what
we know it as now until 1841 when
senator john calhoun realized it could
be used to protect minority rights which
he defined as my right to own minorities
calhoun wanted to ensure that the
slave-owning minority of senators would
be able to override the majority of
senators who didn't own slaves so they
could protect slavery so on the surface
the filibuster seems fine but if you
look closer it's very racist just like
mel gibson
originally in order to filibuster you
had to stand up and talk the whole time
so while you could delay a bill all
filibusters eventually ended when the
dude got sleepy or had to pee or had to
go polish his top hat i don't know what
people did back then
the point is at some point the
filibuster used to end but that changed
during the jim crow era now anytime a
story skips from slavery times to jim
crow times you know it's not going
anywhere good
in 1917 rule 22 was introduced rule 22
requires a super majority of senators to
stop a filibuster sounds good right it
even has the word super in it but in
practice until 1964
the super majority was only used to stop
civil rights legislation that mean
that every other bill could pass with 51
votes but civil rights bills effectively
needed 67 to get past the inevitable
filibuster isn't that crazy it's like oh
no no it's a totally neutral thing it
just somehow only ever gets used to hurt
black people you know like police
the record for the longest one-man
filibuster is held by strom thurmond who
also holds the record for most racist
sounding name
they may as well have named him
segregation oh confederate
in 1957 thurman filibustered the civil
rights act for 24 hours do you know how
much you have to hate someone to stand
on your feet and talk for a whole day i
have several terrible ex-boyfriends and
the longest i can go on any one of them
is 15 minutes after that i'm too tired
to keep caring even civil rights bills
that should pass easily get caught up by
filibusters there are
anti-lynching bills that haven't been
passed by the senate 200 we can get
millions of americans to make their own
sourdough bread but we can't get 60 to
vote against lynching
even crazier these days senators don't
even have to show up to work to
filibuster any senator can send an email
and if 60 other senators don't feel like
challenging it that's enough to
filibuster a bill and the senator
doesn't even have to tell the american
people why
and i think they should if you're
getting paid by my tax dollars to not
make lynching illegal i want you to have
to stand up there and say why and i want
you to be wearing really pointy
uncomfortable shoes when you do it also
i'm sure every speech would start out
with some pretty language about states
rights or something but there is no way
a racist can talk that long without
saying something racist and i want to
see it i think it would be funny
so
now you're thinking okay just because
the filibuster started out racist and
then was only used to be racist for a
long time that doesn't mean it's racist
now right
oh you sweet summer child it's true that
these days the filibuster is used for a
wider variety of issues but any guesses
on when republicans set the record for
doing the most filibusters
can you guess who was in office
i'll give you one more guess
that's right so the filibuster is like
when you see a white person buying brown
makeup on halloween
technically they could be using it for
anything but they're probably gonna do a
racism so that's how we got to where we
are now thanks in large part to the
filibuster we are still struggling with
black people's voting rights don't
believe me ask representative park
cannon the georgia lawmaker who got
arrested just for knocking on the door
of someone who was trying to pass a
voter suppression law
she got charged with a felony
just kidding she got charged with two
can you imagine telling someone marching
in the 60s that we still wouldn't have
this stuff figured out by 2021 they'd be
so disappointed then they'd be like but
you guys have flying cars right and
you'd have to be like oh no but we have
automatic sinks but they don't recognize
black people sorry the future is bad
the filibuster is keeping black
americans from having full voting rights
and it's keeping all americans from
being safe from gun violence and frankly
the word itself sounds very stupid
democrats should get rid of it or at
least make senators see how long they
can talk without letting the n-word slip
out this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you